hello and welcome to this video playing
I am Satya
ha Gyung okay so we have them the retina
opening now yeah this is good yeah but
it's a kind of move that you better know
and I don't really know it all that well
here there is a funky new g5 come on
let's play it it's a really really cool
move and he does not respond immediately
this is a good sign indicating that yes
maybe does not know it that really we
can only make an assumption down you
have white takes I've got this tempo ii
v you know it looks extremely oops it
looks extremely yeah like an extreme
measure if you if you want to if you
want to use that expression what black
is doing here but i think it is quite
playable not that I'm an expert at
middle him okay so he's moving the night
all over the place what do we do here I
need to be ready to castle him this one
what do we maybe I need to be more
direct
what a wacky position and it's truly
truly strange okay so when I have six
problem
yeah I'm lacking a pawn but what I do
have is lots of space very yet pawn or
d3
I mean objectively I'm kind of doubting
that this is totally fine for black but
it is a really remarkable way of playing
okay that is really really annoying I
think as weird as it looks but I have to
play it like that the issue here is
probably the some g4 push g4 I have
three and my centers crumbling a little
bit that is probably going to be a huge
problem yeah I mean if I can trade
Queens I think I'm okay
very very clearly I'm okay if he trades
now you know but it's not a bad sign
the last Queen to e7 I can try to insist
on the trade 20 obliges okay I didn't
think that this was so important the
pawn on c7 that's one of the weirdest
positions ever okay b6 is unfortunately
also hanging
I still have some space and it's not
super simple to play but objectively I'm
probably in trouble
okay take like this
I mean how bad is that
I can mmm look look - see - that's not
so clear actually
I'm two points down yeah I didn't even
count the whole timer because it felt
like I will be down on material anyway
and it really is pointless to determine
if it's two pawns or one pawn or
whatever yeah it's a quite a bit of
material down okay so how to do that
now the knight should come to see four
that would be great it's the way to do
that he wants to push push this of
course it's not super simple for white
to make any headway in this position I'm
taking me five I mean it's the minor
piece ending a simple win not entirely
certain I'm kind of blocking out his
bishop you know in a weird way
yeah I'm stopping all that like he's not
breaking in here anyway
now threatening king bee - yeah that I'm
not playing for when a lady think this
is winning for black at least
objectively speaking and this is this
woman up should have won crap right okay
I've got the apron the airport is quick
you know it's too quick what a weird
game yeah
utterly weird
yeah it's probably not very satisfied
with this understandably I wouldn't be
because white certainly was winning but
it was difficult to play if you ask me I
think it was difficult so let's have a
look this is one of the weirdest
openings ever but I don't think it's too
bad at least when I looked at it a while
ago where there might have been some
some new development or so yeah him this
is so so strange
okay five maybe a five wasn't great but
I'm really more curious and how he yeah
in the middle game let's aim yeah this
must be really really not good
so I took it and no Knight c3 is a
possible improvement but I don't think
this can be bad yeah that that must be
good for White Knight c3 2006gy yeah
like here here must be in a really bad
shape
absolutely queen g6 Queen age form their
Queen f6 really begging for the trade
and I was happy that he traded but of
course objectively speaking it should be
excellent no this happened oh this is
kind of normal and now I went for the
development F takes he takes b6 so I
need to keep me six this should be seven
yeah and here f4 f4 looks like a good
option
I cannot take here there is a check so I
have to take here and then shop 63 that
looks very good okay this is already
giving me a little something I feel ya
if you the engine's evaluation has gone
down to like one which sounds bearable
and here
quite a bit of positional compensation
already and the engine is unequal yeah I
don't
I'm not surprised that's two points down
but the bishop on g2 somehow is a bad
piece and quite quickly we got to
position where I'm playing for Windows
here it's very difficult yeah and then
Turkey the engine is showing a black we
know already I'm amazing
Oh f4 was even stronger as rook c1 in
our drawers
does it really draw a little check
taketake it's possible I'm not doubting
that very much but like him this I
cannot force a win with the two against
one point probably because I would need
the Knights to get a promotion going and
the knight has to stay on f6 to block
everything okay so look c1 was probably
draw port difficult decision yeah it's
already completely winning here look c1
will firmly also win but this is just
too quick there was a really strange
game but it was kind of to be expected
if you play such a sharp opening okay
guys thanks for watching